افاد مراسل الجزيره بوصول فريقه من
الاطباء المتطوعين في الهلال الاحمر
القطري الى منطقه شمال غرب سوريا عبر معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا واضاف مراسل
الجزيره ان الفريق مكون من 12 طبيبا من
مختلف الاختصاصات وذلك لدعم القطاع الطبي
في مناطق المركوبه بسبب الزلزال
بالنظر الهواء ينضم باب الهوى وينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره صهيب خلف مره اخرى اذا وصول
فريق الاطباء المتطوعين في الاحمر القطري
حدثنا عن هذا الجانب صهيب
نعم وصل قبل قليل الاراضي السوريه اول وفد
طبي ضمن وفد الهلال الاحمر القطري دخل
الاراضي السوريه قبل قليل سينتقل الى
المستشفيات في محافظه ادلب ويقوم بتقديم
الخدمات لهذه المستشفيات ويمكن لي هنا ان
استضيف محمد ابراهيم صلاح مدير قطاع
الاغاثه والتنميه الدوليه في الهراء في
الهلال الاحمر القطري سيد محمد حدثنا عن
مهماتكم داخل سوريا التي تتوقعون تنفيذها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طبعا الان نحن
وصلنا الى معبر باب الهوى كاول فريق طبي
يدخل الى من خلال هذا المعبر ان شاء الله
باذن الله متوجهين الى منطقه ادلب مدينه
ادلب راح نقدم فيها الخدمات الطبيه الصحيه
مع فريقنا المتطوع الطبي الحمد لله ف فيه
عدد من التخصصات ارتعينا ان هي مهمه جدا
صراحه في هذا في يعني لمساعده الناس
الصراحه في ازمتهم المنكوبين والمتضررين
والمصابين ان شاء الله باذن الله من خلال
فريقنا راح يكون في اجراء عمليات في
الجراحات العامه في العظام في ايضا في
الاطفال الصغار متخصصين ايضا في اليد
والجراحات التجميليه ايضا معنا طبيب نفسي
راح يجلس ايضا مع المتضررين والمانكوبين
جلسات خاصه يهون عليهم الامر صراحه لانه
الامر جدا صعب والجميع يعني ما كان يتخيل
يحصل الامر بهذه الشده وهذه القسوه حقيقه
لكن الحمد لله على كل حال وباذن الله
الهلال الاحمر القطري يستطيع ويقدم ان شاء
الله خلال هذه المجموعه وايضا لدينا
مجموعات من الاطباء الاخرين ان شاء الله
سياتون تباعا باذن الله ان شاء الله تقديم
خدماتهم من خلال المشافي الموجوده وباذن
الله الهلال الاحمر القطري سيقيم مشفى
ميداني في يقدم كل الامكانيات الموجوده
لدينا حقيقه باذن الله ايضا المعدات تاتي
تباعا باذن الله ايضا مع الفرق الطبيه
باذن الله نستطيع ان نحن نقدم شيء
لاخواننا السوريين المصابين في هذه الازمه
اما في الحقيقه كنا يوم امس في المستشفيات
في المنطقه الحدوديه الكوادر الطبيه تعبت
بشكل كبير من خلال كل العمل التي قدمته
ولا شك ان وصولكم سوف يساعدهم لكن ماذا عن
المتضررين من الزلزال الذين ينتشرون في
مراكز الايواء ويعيشون اوقات صعبه حقيقه
الحمد لله بالتوفيق رب العالمين ايضا
مباشره ثاني يوم من حصول الكارثه الهلال
الاحمر القطري قدمت قرابه 4,800 سله
غذائيه تم توزيعها مباشره على على
المتضررين وايضا حاليا التوزيع ايضا مستمر
الى الان عندنا ان شاء الله باذن الله في
خطتنا راح يتم انشاء مخيم ايضا لايواء
المتضررين خاصه الناس اللي فقدوا منازلهم
مساكنهم راح يتم ان شاء الله تسكنه في خيم
مؤقته لحين ان شاء الله باذن الله
الانتهاء من البناء عندنا قرى سيتم
افتتاحها قريبا وايضا تم اعتماد قرى جديده
ايضا سكنيه سيتم بناءها ان شاء الله خلال
الفتره القادمه وهذا ان شاء الله عملنا في
من خلال فريق نسوان في الداخل السوري او
فريقنا الموجود متواجد في غازي عنتاب